[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je ne suis
pas venu seul
je voudrais vous présenter trois enfants
trois enfants que j'ai eu la chance de
connaître asseman malek et rayen ils
habitent tous les trois le quartier de
hay al elle non loin d'ici d'ailleurs à
ce moment est la preuve même que les
enfants peuvent nous donner à nous les
adultes une grande le sens de la vie
asma est atteinte de nanisme chose qui
aurait dû faire d'elle un enfant
renfermé et triste mais non en revanche
elle a décidé de prendre sa revanche sur
la vie
elle a 13 ans elle est pétillante elle
apprend tous les jours à se surpasser
néanmoins elle rêve d'une chose c'est
d'être nageuses mais c'est exclu parce
qu'elle vient d'être éjecté d'un cours
de natation parce qu'elle empêcher les
autres d'avancer
melek profondément malentendantes
et pourtant elle rêve d'être chanteuse
ne pouvant pas se payer un appareil
auditif
elle rencontre tous les jours d'énormes
difficultés à l'école et dans toutes les
structures qu'elle fréquente
c'est normal parce que rien n'est adapté
pour elle la hyène cadet d'une fratrie
de cinq enfants issus d'une famille
plutôt isolé n'ayant jamais connu son
papa puisque son papa est parti depuis
très longtemps sur un bateau de fortune
et ne renie jamais revenu sa maman
formidable elle fait vivre sa famille au
gré de boulot précaire qu'elle voudrait
bien trouver ryan sans rêver très simple
vivre comme tous les autres enfants
j'ai oublié de me présenter je suis
salman et grains j'ai 40 ans je
travaillais l'unesco et j'ai moi aussi
trois enfants de 11 13 et 16 ans asma
malek et ryan pourraient être mes
enfants d'ailleurs ils ont d'énormes
dénominateur commun avec les miens et
avec tant d'autres enfants pour n'en
citer qu'un
l'amour de la musique moi même
profondément attaché à la musique
si haase malek el hayet n'avait été mes
enfants il aurait baigné dans la musique
depuis leur jeune âge à ce moment-là
qu'est la hyène aurait intégré un
conservatoire de musique dès l'âge de 6
ans au même titre que l'école parce que
c'est très important et c'est pas moi
même c'est pas moi qu'ils inventent
polka revel j d'ailleurs ou écrit plus
tôt la musique devrait être la deuxième
langue la plus importante en signer dans
toutes les écoles du monde
si haase malek et la hyène avait été mes
enfants ils joueraient déjà d'un
instrument de leur choix mais asseman
malek et rennes n'ont jamais écouté ni
même approché ni même toucher ou encore
moins apprivoiser un instrument jusqu'à
il ya un an quand ils ont eux aussi
intégrer un conservatoire à douar que
j'ai eu l'énorme plaisir de fonder avec
une bande d'amis et qui a eu lieu du
domicile dans leur quartier le quartier
de khallat l'est je vais me permettre
et c'est là que j'ai connu asseman melek
et rennes je vais me permettre de vous
les représenter à nouveau
noah doit liste asseman et sans piccolo
un violon conçu rien que pour l adapter
à sa taille pour que plus jamais on ne
lui disent tu empêches les autres
d'avancé où tu ne peux pas suivre les
autres
melek
qui répètent les mélodies aux sons des
vibrations qu'elle ressent pour
surpasser tous les jours sa sourde gt
rien alors le rebelle fait brandir sa
batterie pour que plus jamais il ne se
sentent seules isolées différents vous
avez bien compris à doit d'être une
histoire de rencontre une rencontre
entre cinq personnes mélomane certes
mais des personnes qui croient que la
musique on la partage et que la musique
peut profondément bouleversé la vie des
individus voire des enfants à doit aussi
est une histoire de inspiration une
inspiration de l système 1 qui grâce à
rosser antonio abreu au venezuela a
permis depuis 1975 et jusqu'à la date
d'aujourd'hui à 3 millions d'enfants
issus des favelas ce du venezuela de
pratiquer la musique 300 orchestre ans
en est et même quelques virtuoses pour
n'en citer qu'un ericsson ruiz qui comme
ryan n'a jamais connu son père et
pourtant en 2002 à 17 ans il était le
plus jeune violoniste jamais admis dans
l'orchestré philharmonique de berlin
pour nous les choses était toute simple
ce qui a commencé comme une expérience
pilote l'été dernier est devenu un
programme d'enseignement musical
notre credo était simple comment rendre
ce qui est fondamental est des milliers
d'enfants tunisien fondamental aussi
pour des millions d'autres
je vous cache pas qu à douar est liée à
un contexte d'action profondément touché
par là on va le dire la misère la
pauvreté la mocheté dans laquelle vivent
ces enfants des quartiers économiquement
défavorisées
nous avons décidé d'agir agir par le
biais de la musique parce que nous
croyons que la musique est la première
arme contre la violence les milieux
hostiles et tout ce qui peut dévaster la
vie des enfants
la musique aussi est un sacré vecteur de
cohésion sociale les choses aujourd'hui
sont très simples nos enfants dès l'âge
de 6 ans en droit d'accéder à la musique
et de pratiquer un instrument toutes les
semaines depuis plus d'un an les cours
théoriques leur s'en dispenser
progressivement le chant et la danse les
accompagne pour une approche corporelle
de la musique
nous l'avons nous leur permettant aussi
d'accéder à d'autres sphères culturelles
comme des visites de musées des master
class des cancers
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que pour
ses enfants avec lesquels nous
travaillons
la musique est le seul moyen de
s'épanouir
c'est peut-être mais même le seul moyen
d'avoir un avenir social décent parce
que si la pauvreté est synonyme
d'isolement de laissés-pour-compte de
violence la musique elle est signe de
beauté de travail en équipe de
motivation et d'ambition des ambitions
qu à douar en un parce qu'elle voudrait
depuis l'été déjà accueillir une
nouvelle promotion et ça va se faire et
elle voudrait s'étendre dans les régions
notamment au kef perso d'un patrimoine
musical inégalée ce que je voudrais que
vous reteniez c'est que à douar n'est
pas une simple structure d'enseignement
musical c'est réellement un exemple ou
une école de vie sociale les enfants
apprennent
de nouveau à coexister ensemble avec des
valeurs toutes les valeurs esthétiques
et éthique que porte la musique et en
allant vers la perfection vers le beau
nous rêvons nous rêvons d'une chose
c'est que as douanes puissent contribuer
profondément est fondamentalement à
construire une nouvelle ère de
l'enseignement musical une ère où les
buts sociaux communs défensif de
l'enfant et de l'adolescent puisse
devenir un vaste but commun ne mettant
plus la société au service de l'art
encore moins au service d'un monopole
d'élite mais l'art au service de la
société au service du plus vulnérable au
service de l'enfant au service de
l'indigné de l'ain firme de tous ceux
qui revendiquent une condition sociale
et une dignité
aujourd'hui adwan a besoin de contaminer
d'inspirer de porter plus fort la voix
de l'enfant juste pour une chose parce
que la tunisie de demain ressemblera à
ses enfants d'aujourd'hui elle
ressemblera à ce que deviendront malek
as main et ryan je vous dis une chose
rallye wolf and les jeunes la merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]